[Music]
outside Vietnam's distinctive
presidential Palace a warm welcome for
U.S President Joe Biden here at the
invitation of Communist Party General
Secretary nuan futron
Vietnam
is a critical power in the world
and a bellwether in this vital region
Hanoi has now moved the United States to
its top diplomatic ranking
President Joe Biden and I on behalf of
both countries have jointly agreed to
elevate the relation between Vietnam and
the United States the comprehensive
strategic partnership for peace
cooperation and sustainable development
Biden said the relationship had evolved
from the bitter past of the Vietnam war
that ended almost 50 years ago and
denied the elevated status was about
containing China
upgraded by lateral ties to the highest
level in Vietnamese diplomacy is largely
symbolic but it's an outcome Washington
has long pursued the change puts the U.S
on the same rank as China and Russia in
Vietnam's a diplomatic relationships
Vietnam is key to Washington's strategy
of diversifying Supply chains away from
China
and Vietnam also stands to benefit from
stronger ties with the U.S as it seeks
to cement its emerging role as a
high-tech manufacturing Hub and also
aims to reduce dependence on Russian
arms
for the longest time in Southeast Asia
we feel that you know with the whole U.S
China rivalry for Southeast Asia the
more that both major Powers engage with
southeast Asia that's always you know
what we wish for that we would still
have good relations with both the US and
China it's a balancing act for Vietnam
but one that appears to ensure Keen
interest from both countries
China's president Xi Jinping is also
expected to make a state visit to Hanoi
in coming weeks
Jessica Washington Al Jazeera Hanoi
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera